good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I'm very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our 2023 2024
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA College of Arts and
Sciences the UVA School of data science
and through a grant from the National
Institutes of General Medical Sciences
since
2016 the foundations of biomedical data
science seminar Series has focused on
the use of data science methodologies
artificial intelligence deep learning
and statistical modeling as they pertain
to different themes in the biomedical
and health scien
our theme for this year is focused on
building Partnerships for generative AI
training in biomedical and clinical
research where every Friday we enjoy uh
lectures from a wide range of leading
thinkers about the issues the promise
the opportunities and hurdles associated
with the emerging um emergence of aib
based methods applied to biomedical
science data types indeed we'd like to
welcome and remind everyone that uh we
are accepting applications for this
year's cycle and it's uh encourage
Junior faculty in particular who are
working in areas such as the development
of General generative AI based methods
which are applied to biomedical research
as well as those Junior faculty actively
utilizing Ai and their biomedical
teaching consider applying we find that
this has been a very exciting and
engaging program bringing together AI
platform developers and University level
Educators this year to better understand
the power of the promise and potential
perils associated with the generative AI
explosion participants selected for our
biomedical data science seminar or
excuse me biomedical data science
Innovation lab program will leverage
these seminar presentations as vital
material for our culminating in-person
manuscript and Grant project development
Workshop to be held at the beia
beachfront Resort located in Sunny San
Diego California in June of 2024 today I
am delighted to welcome our speaker
Prince aier from the University of
Virginia's School of data science uh
Prince is an associate professor of data
science and is the director of the
residential master of science and data
science program here at the University
of Virginia pring prior to joining the
school of data science he was an
assistant professor of Statistics at UVA
where he taught courses um on the
introduction to data science using R
statistical analysis using python as
well as mathematical statistics his
research includes multiple comparison
studies studies of survival analysis as
well statistics and data Science
Education his research in multiple
comparisons is focused on developing new
and Powerful methodologies for testing
multiple hypotheses simultaneously
including its applications on high
throughput genomic data and detecting of
differentially expressed genes between
groups those for example with cancer
versus those who are cancer-free
currently in collaboration with the
Cardiology department at UVA Health um
Prince helps with statistical risk
analysis pertaining to heart failure um
and his SE Arch results in countless
Publications and statistics as well as
in agriculture business and in medical
journals and he holds his PhD and his
master's degree in statistics from
Temple University and a master's degree
in mathematics from Ball State
University his uh bachelor's degree was
obtained at Northern Kentucky University
and in continuing our 2023 2024
biomedical data science seminar series
theme Prince's lecture today is entitled
acceding to the use of AI Tools in
education he will note that the influx
of AI related tools is really Revolution
revolutionizing our world AI tools are
particularly transforming learning and
education as we know it the number of
Educators who are adverse to using AI
tools and their instructions is probably
much higher though than those who have
embraced it as part of instruction the
reasons for that um are that some if not
most Educators have some fears about
incorporating AI tools and his talk is
going to be discussing the impacts of
these AI tools as they applied higher
education and how we can incorporate
them successfully into education as
always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via YouTube and
so if you're watching us via YouTube
thank you so much for joining us and
also our specially selected 20 2023 2024
biomedical data science Innovation lab
participants and alumni are encouraged
to submit any questions they have via
the chat feature in their YouTube
sessions I will synthesize these
questions and I will ask them on your
behalf during the last 10 minutes or so
of the lecture and with that Prince
welcome on this very snowy day and we
are looking forward to your
presentation thank you so much Jack uh
for the nice introduction and uh I want
to thank uh the biomedical uh data
science Innovations lab for inviting me
for for this talk and uh thank you uh
Jack and your team for putting this
together um so um I would start off uh
by saying uh that uh I actually don't do
direct uh Research into AI methods in
education
um I care about education I love
teaching so I do a lot of uh research on
you know how to effectively teach uh
statistics and data science courses uh
AI is a new field as you all know uh so
uh this talk actually gave me
opportunity to really really think about
um Ai and you know over the past couple
of years we be all of us have been
inundated with a lot of AI tools and so
uh this gave me opportunity to actually
look into them so these ideas presented
here mostly uh come from me I actually
um so when I was about to give this talk
I was like since I'm going to talk about
generative AI uh let me actually go in
there and just type my topic in chat GPT
by the way uh my topic and I'm like give
me an outline for this talk uh I must
say the outline was pretty good
generated by chat GPT um but then so I
developed it a little bit and then I was
thinking about and I'm like this is
sounds very good but that's not me so uh
and we have to we are conf confed with a
lot of this uh with our students who we
think are actually using that to do
their uh assigned work and so I was like
this is not me so I actually retreated
and then put together something that
reflect exactly what I'm thinking uh
nonetheless I did use it a little bit
and I'll point it out uh when we get to
those slides um so I have four main
things to talk about today uh first I
want to begin with what is AI uh AI is
like uh I remember a long time ago when
I used to think about AI I used to think
about robots and uh how they you know
they're going to be designed as human
and taking over all our jobs uh now it's
much much broader than that now it could
be a lot of machine learning deep model
models uh large language models that
would do this for me and I'll get into
more of that today um but I'll start off
with AI in the context of Education uh
what does the AI tools in the context of
Education means um typically we we want
to look at trends of AI tools and
investment in AI that typically is a
good indicator it's not always the case
uh of what uh the impacts of AI are and
so we'll look at around the world what
are Venture Capital Investments and AI
tools and then I'll begin with a
motivation with my own class that I
taught last semester in communicating
with data at the school of data science
uh how basically every topic that I
talked about in in the class can be done
in a few minutes if you know what you're
doing in say chart GPT so I I'll use
that as a motivator and then uh we'll
talk about impact of AI Tools in
education um I want you to be ready
because I'm I'm going to pull you I want
you all to be involved so I'll put up a
a QR code and ask you uh what are your
opinions so in terms of one word what
are some of the words that come to you
when you think about AI Tools in
education so uh be ready for that uh at
some point and then um we'll get into
why are some Educators really averse to
a tools and education and then how do we
adapt as educators I think that is the
key part and that's probably the most
important point to uh wrap up with so
let's begin with what is AI um and again
AI has a broad definition uh in this
context I'm going to talk about what are
AI tools that are basically transforming
education as we know it so uh when we
talk about AI in terms of Education we
mean just generative Ai and so there are
Audi based models there are video based
so in terms of audio based by the way uh
I was recently we have an Alexa at home
and uh uh my family and I my wife and I
and my two kids my son is actually Four
my daughter is one and a half we were
playing with Alexa so now like if my son
is on the iPad and I'm like Alexa put on
the time of uh uh 60 Minutes my son goes
right after me it's like Alexa cancel
the timer so uh he really you know Alexa
can really hear all of us and act uh as
we speak uh there are video based models
there are art based models there are
um 3D based model and I'll bring a
picture up in just a little bit but what
is really really changing us is actually
large language models uh Now language
models have been around for a long time
and by the way uh my colleague Brian
Wright and RF Alvarado gave a talk on
this platform um not too long ago so you
can find the videos they get into more
about uh what large language models
actually do uh so language model have
been around for a while what is really
really changing uh um us and everything
that we do that's why people want to
talk about AI all the time it's actually
large language models um so when I think
about large language models um again let
me go back to my son so the first two
years of his life he spent at home with
us because thus he was born around covid
um and when he started speaking uh the
first uh maybe words that he spoke you
could tell that he gathered that
information from us so when he was
speaking we were like I look at my wife
and we like he's he's saying exactly
what we we say to him um now that he's
for his diction has exploded uh and
again I think my my colleague RAF aado
called that communicative competent he
he I don't even have an argument with
him anymore uh this morning I was trying
to get him to school uh schools were
delayed a little bit here uh because
it's snowing outside in Charlottesville
right now and um I was like put your
coat on put your shoes on and he's like
Daddy why are you telling me exactly
what to do I I tell myself what to do so
I don't even argue with him anymore
because he always wins but uh the reason
I bring this up is um if he's on the
iPad and he's for so we we got him a
little iPad present uh for Christmas and
uh if if I'm talking to him or my wife
is talking to him and he doesn't pay
attention what we usually do is uh I'm
like are you listening so I soon as he
hears are you listening and I start with
the phrase I will and I ask him to
complete the sentence he would know that
what I'm going to say after that is take
your iPad away right and again the
reason why he's doing that is around the
time that he's have the iPad that's
exactly how my phrases are with him so
his first guess would be take uh second
guest will be iPad third guest will be a
and he will complete that sentence um
just because he's been inundated with
that uh since he got the iPad um large
language models work exactly like that
um they take a guess at the first word
based on weights put together I mean
they spend vast uh data on the internet
and So based on weights and
probabilities um they can detect what
the first guess should be if the first
guess is uh good then the second guess
will be followed will follow that but if
the first guess is actually wrong then
everything that comes after that will be
uh uh uh will not make any sense right
so they span the internet um so if there
if the guesses are coming from say fake
news whatever they spit out it's going
to be fake news as well so um uh it's
it's fascinating and again we all know
that the goal of AI or generative AI is
uh prediction and so if they and theyve
the predictions of large language models
have been so good recently that it's a
little scary and that's why we all want
to talk about large language models and
uh AI tools and education all right so
on the next slide I want to show you um
in terms of uh the model so so down here
in the blue is basically the model layer
uh these companies open AI is basically
the the biggest landscape in terms of a
uh AI CH GPT uh I have the free version
which I'll show you I have ch GPT 3.5
but uh um large language model can be
focused on text code GPT actually do
some of the image stuff too and under
test these are all the stuff that they
can do uh and for us in education
generative writing is a big deal
uh for folks in the humanities uh for me
uh in um data science and statistic
codin and it's it's amazing what um CH
GPT can do in terms of code um but and
there are a lot more uh video based
models and speech and all that stuff and
these are the companies that are on the
the front lines and the models that they
built uh to do this uh very nicely uh
the next slide is actually about all
these uh applications of generative AI
so the this group of apps are actually
on um GPT which is general purpose
technology um so open AI is there chat
GPT is uh definitely the the one that we
know uh I don't actually have the paid
version of chat GPT I don't have the
chat GPT for uh I have the 3.5 but it
does even that it does uh wonders uh so
but just for you guys to get an idea if
you want to really really focus on speed
generation these are the ones that um
are available and stuff so that's a
that's a lot all right now I talked
about earlier um why do we care
typically Financial Trends tell us
something um so around maybe 2021 I have
a colleague uh that I collaborate with
in uh baton uh School uh UVA and he told
me about chat GPT and back then I was
like um oh man when I was in grad school
around
maybe 2010 I don't even remember anymore
um there was this so I was a math major
I did my masters in math and um there
was W from alpha then uh that was a that
was groundbreaking then uh you could put
in all these complex anti-derivative
stuff and we just spit out for you step
by step how to do anti-derivative how to
do derivatives it was it was
groundbreaking and you know we heard
about it a little bit and then I don't
think I heard about them when I was
actually getting my PhD I never used
them again beyond that but this uh AI
tools Char GPT uh is very groundbreaking
and again take a look at the numbers
here uh going back to 2013 there was the
30 million investment this is across the
world by the way so uh this is all the
countries around the world to 2021 3.6
billion
2023 the capital Venture Capital
Investments 17.8 billion can you imagine
look at this jump right so everybody's
thinking about it are the business are
people in business are thinking about it
and incorporating uh AI Tools in how to
do business business and how people do
things uh medical field um Academia for
for people like us we're also thinking
about it and by the way this data is
actually coming from um deal room. um so
it's uh it's basically exploding and the
money tells you a lot about that okay so
what I really quickly want to do is so
again last uh so by the way before I
joined School of data science I was in
the stat department so last semester or
the summer was my first time at the
school of data SCI as UVA um uh andot my
first class that I taught for the school
was uh Comm communicating with data
where basically I teach students how to
uh visualize data using R and then more
emphasis though on the communicating
part how do you communicate what your
visualization is doing so teaching them
how to make compelling graphs and stuff
like that was one of my um goals there
so um so just to motivate that there are
a few topics that I talk about in this
class and I want to give you an example
example of what I did uh some a topic
that I talked about and uh how I'm going
to show you how CH GPT would tweat this
so I'm going to just change screens
quickly um since the NFL player um uh uh
NFL or for those of you who like
football uh the the playoff season is
here um so this is a data from
nfl.com and what I want you to show you
here is so if you just type in nfl.com
and go to Stats the first option that is
play stats and the first tab is passing
and you can actually change the year
here uh 2024 is basically the playoff
season but 2023 is all the uh games that
were done in 202 so let's stick with
2023 for now and in terms of passing
most of the players that make all the
passes uh are the quarterbacks so this
page shows the top 25 quarterbacks um in
uh the NFL in 2023 it's probably changed
a little bit because some of those good
quarterbacks actually lost their playoff
games uh in in terms of passing passing
yards so there's data here the player
name um the pass yards uh completion
percentage touchdown I'm going to focus
on those three variables for now so an
activity that we will do in class is
data scraping uh and by the way I did I
do warn my students that if you're going
to scrape data from the web make sure
that you are actually um uh making sure
that it's a public website that you can
actually script data because you might
you can get in trouble if you script
data from a private uh uh website so I
just want to make sure that uh we are on
the same page on that but to be able to
scrape this data so basically we want to
be able to bring this data into R and
then script the data clean it up and
then visualize the data and then
communicate it for example right now
data scraping is a very technical thing
you have to think about something called
a CSS selector where you look at the
HTML page to get exact noes that
correspond to each of the columns that
we're going to scrape and so it's very
technical and so um we go we take about
I think I take about maybe two courses
uh two 15 minutes classes to talk to
talk about data scraping just to give
you an idea how how much time uh I spend
in class uh doing that so we want to
scrape the data and then visualize the
data uh so I'm going to switch to
another Tab and by the way if you can't
see uh I'm going to switch to R and
again you don't have to know R for this
talk I already have the code preset for
us so I'm just going to run these codes
quickly because um I just uh have them
done and what I'm doing here the first
line here is telling R hey I'm about to
use this website go to the HTML page of
that website so I'm going to call it uh
player stats and then I'll go ahead and
scrip the name of the players the
passing yards and then the completion
percentage and then maybe the touchdown
I said touchdown as well and then I'm
going to come up with the data frame uh
but the original data set that I'm going
to get from this exercise is actually um
not
clean and so I spend about so because
when we're talking about you know you
know visualizing data you basically have
to get the data in the correct format
before you can visualize them so if you
if you scrape a numerical data it might
come out as a character variable uh on
the other hand and so what I want to do
here is be able to clean the data and we
spend maybe about a week and a half
talking about data cleaning because it's
so important otherwise you can't really
do much with with the data so what I
have here is a few uh lines of data
cleaning again we don't have to know any
of this so once I'm done I basically
have I'm going to move my zoom screen uh
I basically have this data set that I'm
going to call it
um
sorry uh clean
data and this is the exactly the same
data set that we just saw on the NFL
website so I have the name of the
players the 25 the passur their
completion percentage and their
touchdowns okay um so this is the data
that after cleaning this is the data I
have the data in R so now what I want to
do is actually just visualize the data
there's a few based on this data there's
a lot of graphs that you can actually
make um but the one that I'm going to
focus on to include all of these
variables all of these columns is uh
actually called a bubble plot and I'll
talk about what a bubble plot actually
does uh because of my screen size and
all um I'll just run this slide and then
actually let's see if we can zoom in um
I don't know are people able to see
hopefully be able to see uh this graph
all right so uh I actually got rid of
the legend because I wanted people to
see exactly the graph uh first so what I
have on my x-axis is the completion
percentage what I have on my y AIS is
the pass yards and it's basically a
scatter plot but I've made the size of
these dots proportional to the number of
touchdown for each of the players uh in
2023 uh for those of you who follow the
NFL
T I can't say the name but two uh from
the uh Cowboys had the most touchdown in
2023 and so his bubble is much bigger
compared to uh somebody like Bryce young
Bryce young uh played for I believe the
Miami Dolphins he was uh uh drafted in
20123 he played a few games and then he
got injured so all the people that you
see down here uh are either backup
quarterbacks or they got injured so
that's why their bubbles are a little
smaller um uh but you could this data is
compellent uh you can think about the
person who have the most
yards having trouble moving this uh Zoom
screen uh but that's that purple uh the
pink bubble over here so people looking
at this graph is compelling people can
see exactly what's going on and again we
will spend time effectively
communicating uh this graph Prince we
were not able to see the graph that
you're showing we're seeing the small
little short version that's down in the
lower right hand corner of your R Studio
screen but we're not seeing the full
size graph all right thank you very much
let me see if I can share again sorry
about that that's
okay and I'm GNA share
that
so uh Jack let me know if you yes so I
think now everybody can see this graph
right yes that's better thank you sir
yeah of course yeah yeah yeah so um so
again like I was saying uh the pink
bubble here is the person with the most
uh yards then that's tour and um all the
people down here were the quarterbacks
that were either injured or they were
backup quarterbacks but this
visualization is very compelling uh I
got rid of the legend but if I showed
the legend everybody looking at that
could be able to uh see what's going
going on uh with these three variables
um and beside that the player names are
on top of each of the bubbles uh you can
actually spread these out a little bit
uh the screen size gets a little messed
up that's why I did not um do um arrow
pointing to each of these three bubbles
here but I made it transparent so you
can at least see um so this is what um
um um you will see uh uh you could be
able to do in this class and again
combined I would spend maybe two and a
half weeks to be able to get to this
point uh uh in this class so now uh let
me go ahead and share back the screen
now what would CH GPT be able to do with
the same thing um and I'm back on the
web browser I I believe people hopefully
people can see the web browser so I'm
going to just go on to chat GPT on open
AI
quickly I already have an account
already uh so the question is how how
would chat GPT do the same thing that I
was just doing and I'll start a new
chart here so I'll first begin with the
data scraping part and so if I go to the
website all I have to do for chat GPT to
be able to recognize that to scrip this
data is actually if I just highlight
this whole page and just copy the page
come to chat GPT I will uh just go to
the message and then post
it and it will be able to read in
everything that I just copied from from
the whole
page all right and so now that I've
copied the page and put it in Char GPT I
could just tell it hey Char GPT go ahead
and scrape data on 25
players uh and I wanted to tell them
exactly what variables to scrape so I
want them to scrape I wanted to scrape
the yards the completion
percentage uh and then also the number
of
touchdowns and once I'm done I'm going
to tell her to actually export this into
an Excel file more specifically a CSV
file which is a Excel file saved as a
comma separated values um uh so get this
variable and save as uh
CSV and it will take him sometimes it
takes him a while to actually it takes
CH GPT a while to actually get get
around this but uh it will do that for
me uh and then once you have the CSV
file you can actually just bring them in
so this will take a moment but it will
do it which it it doesn't go through any
of the technical stuff uh it will do it
uh looks like it's still thinking I
don't know if my screen is
Frozen um but once it's done scraping I
don't even have to tell it the web page
again it has memory where it can
actually use that memory that of the of
the data that it just scraped I can tell
it to just visualize uh make the same
plot as as a word um uh in R and um see
did scrape all these 35 variables now
sometimes when I put in this code it
will save it as an P CSV file I can
download it and import it into R so I
skip the data script import sometimes it
would do something like that where it
gives me the code uh or basically I can
copy this and save it as a CSV file and
then I can import it into R but
basically that skript all that technical
data scrip and component that we talked
about uh in the class all right so now
that it has the data actually don't have
to tell it to use the data anymore now I
could just tell it um make a bubble
plot uh with the x-axis equal to uh C
completion percentage uh the Y AIS is
equal to the pass
yards and then uh I'm going to fill each
of those dots with the touchdown
variable um so for those of who for
those of you who have char GPT 4 it
probably will scrape it and put in a CSV
file for you for those of you who have
char GPT uh for or it might be able to
write the code and actually display the
visualization for you right there too
the version which is the free version
that I have which is
3.5 all it does is will give me the r
code to be able to actually what it did
here is actually did it in
Python and what I could tell it if I
wanted to make sure that this is in R uh
in R I can
say use ggplot
2 to to make a bubble
plot and it will give me the equivalent
code exactly very similar to the code
that I I showed you earlier and would
think about using the data set and
writing the equivalent code that would
do exactly what I I did uh to show you
that graph uh from earlier so it's still
working on it
but look at this beauty this is the
code um it does everything so perfectly
quickly and again I spent two and a half
weeks talking about this in class and it
could do it in like two seconds well not
two seconds but two minutes right uh
it's amazing what it could do uh here I
se in this code that it actually um did
not do a few things if I the title is
not centered but I can tell it hey go
ahead and center the title and again I
don't have to type the same prompt as
before I could just tell it from that it
has the memory Center the
title uh of the plot and it would just
do that it would give me the same code
now with the c the title
centered um so it's it's amazing right
and that is doing that for me and that
code it just added it to it right so um
so does that mean so I I can pick every
topic in that class as long as I can
prompt it correctly it gives me a valid
code this code is actually valid you you
have to have the idea to be able to
criticize what you're getting from chat
GPT so now does that mean that my course
is going to be
obsolete uh and this is where we get
into all that kind of stuff and I think
that no I I would never I think there's
a lot of fears in the academic world
that Char dput is going to take over our
jobs I don't think it is the reason why
I'm able to do all of this in about two
two minutes is because I know exactly
what I want to AR GPT think about if
you're a student you don't know anything
about data visualization you don't know
anything about coding and R you don't
know anything about data scraping you
will not be able to prompt it to give
you this respons us and so that's why I
think that we're going to be around in
perpetuity educators are always going to
be here so I think let me I Swatch that
fears uh among some Educators there um
but um but that definitely mean that I
need to think about the way that I teach
courses and I need to think about the
way that I make assessments so that I
can really really test the students
understanding uh of the
material okay so and I'll get into more
of these uh nitty uh uh coming up but
that is the beauty and again I entreat
you guys for those of you who are
teaching uh courses to be able to um
just pick a topic that you talk about in
your class see just run it through the
free version of CH GPT see what it it
would be able to do so I'm back on my
slides here I'm going to move on and
we'll come back to how do I mitigate any
of these stuff so that my students are
actually learning and uh I'm also
relevant right but that's definitely
should should give it a pause and think
about how we think about education in
general uh hopefully everybody's able to
see my slides now so um so I'm want to
uh do a quick poll coming up but I want
to actually focus on the impacts of AI
in education
so um I will go ahead so here's a QR
code I need to present this so you can
actually access it but think about what
kind of words come to your mind when you
think about the impact of AI Tools in
education and let me switch screens
again and I'm going to go to my poll
everywhere here and I make I want to
make sure that we can actually
um start the
poll this
uh all right so let me present this so
everybody so that's the
um um the QR code if you scan it you
don't have to register so you can skip
skip that and uh let me wait a few
seconds to see how many people are
responding uh I don't know Jack if you
everybody's able to see my screen um on
the
web yes we can
yeah all right so I hear I see a First
Response there intimidating I totally
agree
go back Uncharted yes so for those of
you who are still thinking about here
the QR code we will give it a few
seconds for people to put in
responses right so now let's see the few
responses that we've gathered so far um
promising I like that that's very
positive uh intimidating
Uncharted uh revolutionary I totally
agree with that um um yeah so this is a
word cloud so I think most people are
thinking promising uh I think that's why
the the the size of the word is
proportional to number of people who
said that uh exciting uh these are all
very good uh I think that people are
more positive on this which I'm very
happy uh to see um exciting so there
they're the same word so I think we we
have about a few people okay empowering
yes yes so yeah that's that's great I'm
I'm happy to hear all those uh
positivity um very good so now let me
come back to my slides here um so I was
thinking the same words that you guys
are were actually just putting on those
uh poll everywhere and um but I want
what I wanted to do was actually go to
CH GP CH GPT what are the impacts of AI
in education and some of these are
coming from CH GPT some of these are
coming from me too and um one of them
that CH GPT said over Reliance on
technology so it knows that uh students
might think uh might just rely on U uh
technology that they're not going to
really focus on the learning and that is
a critical point there and I think most
educated that are worried about this are
right because um excessive use of
Technology actually hinder our
development um in terms of problem
solving and critical thinking so um
definitely uh if we rely on it too much
or if I stent rely on it too much that's
going to block that kind of the brain
and that is the learning part that we
want them to be able to take advantage
of um um there are a lot of equity
issues and biases in AI algorithms so
for example the biases and AI algorithms
is it's spanning the internet to be able
to come up with these uh responses um so
if there's a lot of fake news out there
if there's a lot of biases in terms of a
particular group of people that will be
highlighted in uh these algorithms as
well um Equity issues there are some
communities in the United States that
are suffering from equ Equity issues in
terms of Education this will actually
make that even higher um because um uh
those people in those communities that
are you know might not be able to you
know even have the access to Internet
and all that so there's there's a lot of
equity issues that can come from these
technology privacy and ethical consern
uh most of these students uh are putting
a lot of a sensitive prompt in um CH GPT
we don't know what open AI is actually
doing with these information so we have
to be cautious of all of that stuff so
there uh privacy concerns out there
um our students uh being in the
classroom um there are these soft scills
that um we're not very aware of but it's
actually happening being able to
communicate with people being able to um
be in a group and working together uh as
a unit um these are soft skills that are
found in the classrooms that if we rely
so much on technology these are going to
be gone um so uh these are some big
concerns there uh there's a lot of
resistance also coming from uh The
Faculty side where they don't trust
these uh um uh large language models or
generative AIS and so people are not
thinking ahead in terms of um trying to
find a way and again I'll we'll talk
more about this a little later in the
slides um but if we can just put our
Assessments in ch GPT and see what it
can spit out uh that will give us an
idea what students are also doing um and
so that resistance I agree with that but
I think that changing that mindset a
little bit and thinking about better
ways to access is probably the way that
I'm thinking at least when I approach my
classes um some of the advantages would
be like students will probably be
working at 2 am in the morning and
they'll send me an email well I'm not
going probably not going to be able to
respond till maybe 9:00 or 10:00 a.m.
but if they have access to AI tools and
they can critically think about the
responses that they are getting then
this can be a tool that they can use
that's 247 where they can actually have
virtual assistants give them answers uh
on what whatever they are trying to
think about right so uh this this is a
positive there so we should definitely
leverage that uh there can also be a lot
of research assistance for those of for
those of us who do research um um so if
you if you're trying to research about
new areas you have to do like a lot of
literature reviews a lot of data
analysis and all that CH GPT can do all
that so you can skip even if you put a
paper into CH GPT and you ask it to
summarize the paper it does a pretty
good job summarizing the paper so you
know exactly what people are doing in
your in your in your area so these are
tools that we can actually use uh as
well uh for those of us in a little bit
of administration
there's a lot of administrative stuff
that AI tools can actually help us do uh
in education um so scheduling admissions
uh we could build chat Bots that could
do stuff much much easier uh these days
so it can actually decrease the burden
uh on us
um um and he is looking into a bit of
the future um if this trend keep going
like the way it is which I I I it's a
higher probability that it would um but
our students are going to be working in
places where they're going to be using
uh tools AI tools so um thinking about
using them or letting allowing them or
maybe leveraging that in our classroom
will help actually prepare them uh for
the future Workforce um and there's so
many long-term advantages to exposure to
AI technology out there I think that uh
so I by the way I grew up in Ghana um uh
and the I think I I started college in
Ghana a little bit um and then I
transfer to uh the United States but
when I was there I remember my first
programming language was in qbasic and
this was around the year 2000 and um it
was a language that I was trying to
learn um we did not have computers my
teacher did not have a computer to
project it for us to be able to actually
see what he's doing so he taught us
coding on the board and can you imagine
that uh these days um and uh so for the
students what we did is the Library had
computers so right after class we go to
the library and try to implement
whatever we learn in class and so
because of that um uh there's a lot of
things so I'm very slow typer for that
reason um but because I did not have uh
that exposure earlier on and so in terms
of this technology given our students
exposure early it's going to be
beneficial to them uh in the long
term um now why are most or some
Educators averse to AI tools um and the
Bigg one is if you just show them how to
do stuff there they're going to use it
to cheat uh but the problem is it's
already out there uh and definitely
there's a lot of for those of us who
have been teaching them for a while you
can definitely tell that there's a lot
of um higher scores if you're teaching
the same things like you used to do and
you're doing the same things like you
used to do uh student scores are very
much much on average that students are
doing much better uh maybe they are but
we can't actually take that leap unless
we actually catch them cheating but
that's a bigger that's a big violation
that's a big uh thing that that we all
have to worry about and we'll get into
how to get around that because we have
to we can design our accessment in such
a way that um these will not again be it
might happen but it might not be that
prevalent um I talked about this earlier
on um there's a lot of Educators that
are like you can't really trust what CH
GPT is doing or what AI tools are doing
in general uh and that's where we come
in we have to teach them how to
critically think and all these responses
that they're getting um and so there's a
lot of those trust worthy issues um my
colleague talk a lot about this uh uh
RAF Alvarado talked about is AI
knowledgeable right um so just like my
son AI is uh I think rap put it uh
communicative competent so they they
understand all these language or all
these diction just like my son uh but
would they um do they gain my son for
example does he is he M ma can he gain
Mastery in a specific as aspect of a
discipline or something like that he's
not there yet he's going to get there
maybe AI will get there too um but just
being able to communicate um is a good
too maybe in some aspect it's
knowledgeable but they don't they can't
do a deeper dive in some of these if
you're teaching a very complicated uh
rigorous math math course uh CH GPT is
going to fail in that region but
teaching these students to be able to
think about even they put a prompt in to
be able to think about the prompt that
they put in um it's going to be um if
it's a correct response or not I think
that is the part that is lacking right
now and that's why we can we can
actually come in to help him do that um
and I talked about this a little bit um
I think most professors are adverse this
because of relevance are we going to be
relevant in the next five years and um I
think that we are going to be relevant
as long as we are ready to adapt to what
we have now um so two weeks of material
being covered in five minutes um that's
a big advancement but if the students
don't know how to do this or how to
query or how to critically think about
it then they will need us right so we
we're still going to be around granted
AI is going to take some jobs uh in in
higher education for for uh for sure um
so now the question is how do we adapt
as Educators um and um some of these uh
work is actually seted at the bottom of
the page um so uh we need professional
development across all universities on
education on understanding uh AI tools
we also just need education on how to
use them effectively uh and I I maybe
I'm jumping the gun here but I think uh
University of Virginia is actually
really thinking about this how to uh get
our students or up at the faculty on the
same page in terms of what is out there
and and how they can actually leverage
it um at least for what whatever they're
doing in the classroom or whatever um
but we we need that across the
board um we need to be and again this is
very important for me uh expect uh
establish expectations for students uh
on AI tools so we have two typically
what I've seen or what I think that most
profess some professors are like like me
I'm like hey feel free to use it I don't
I don't care if you use it you can use
it on your homework you can use it on
your test you can use it on whatever you
want uh but some professors are strictly
telling them don't use it uh and then
there's this these other group that are
in the nebulous region that are telling
them they're not telling them to use it
they're not also telling them not to use
it and so some students use it and some
students don't use it so that create
this inequity uh issue among students
and then also some some most of our
students can afford the paid version of
CH GPT or uh generative AI Tools in
general so for those of them who can
afford it um that's some fair to the
other group of students right so that's
why establishing these expectations and
you know making sure that students are
aware uh of where you stand in terms of
your course is so important um we need
to be able to ensure and this come back
to the T back to the previous Point
transparency um and then accountability
uh tell the students that if you use a
CH GPT or any AI tool make sure that you
let me know um and most of these
students are going to go out there in
the job market they're going to start
looking for jobs and might be writing a
sh Shakespeare because they're using GPT
but they're not telling people what
they're using and I think that is where
the accountability come in um and so
that is so important that uh we we we
highlight this to to our students and
again I don't mean that this would be
policies but these are General
guidelines that we can let faculty know
uh in the ad uh in terms of
administration um and I'll talk a lot
about this how do we explore changes in
our course especially how do we actually
make sure that students are
understanding what we're teaching them
without the traditional framework so
like in my course that I just talked
about in the example if I tell them hey
go ahead to the go to the NFL website
script data make a bubble plot well if I
if my questions are that way then
they're definitely going to do that
easily in like five minutes right and so
how do we get around that and I'll get
into all that uh maybe in my last couple
of slides um and then think about what
you University's aror code is and how it
applies to your course uh and I think
this is a very useful guideline out
there and this is actually from uh
Virginia Tech uh Business School uh
that's the cided down
here um so now the question is how do we
leverage AI tools uh in our courses um
and I'll focus on two main thing the
first one is redesign curriculum with AI
Tools in mind uh and the first thing
that we have to think about is we all
have learning outcomes for our course um
so the first thing is look at those
learning outcomes and then maybe take a
given semester try to Pilot with AI
Tools in mind pilot that in your
classroom and then evaluate how students
perform in your courses and uh and I'm
not saying that make big changes um but
make the changes gradually uh to you're
comfortable with fully you know
integrating AI Tools in your in your in
your curriculums and then AI tools are
going to get better on this trend and on
these in investment tracks they're going
to get better so you have to basically
think about revision to what you're
doing and repeat the process I mean
that's how we're going to stay relevant
uh uh in the in this uh age of AI um the
second part is uh making your
assessments in such a way that um it's
proof
uh of of AI tools and so for that uh
instead of having rigid questions that
we typically used to ask uh think about
maybe asking how how would you do this
what would you do here uh so in that
example that I showed you um I need to
think about open-ended questions so I'll
tell students go to a public website of
your choice and then think about the
data there think about how you bring it
in and think about specific graphs that
you will make to visualize the variables
that you have so in that way I'm not
making it so stringent on One Direction
but making it more abroad and I think
that actually really really uh is
important it helps students think about
framing questions and uh even research
uh I think if we train students that way
that really helped their development uh
in terms of research too um so once you
create an assessment for a class and you
could do this for those of us who are
teaching courses think about putting
your questions through chat GPT first
before you actually um uh and see how AI
would do with these assessments now if
they can readily find the answers then
think about not tricking them but think
about how to invoke evoke that uh
critical thinking part of their brain so
this is a very good exercise uh now
every test I do or homework whatever
that I give to the students I do them in
Char GP to see what responses I get
granted
uh every question you run through chat
GPT will give you different answers so
but typically it's very similar um to
what students will actually get from uh
using your
assessment um and I've actually started
doing this as well uh think about maybe
instead of giving written exams maybe
maybe we can assess them orally now some
of us that are teaching really if you
teach a very large class it might not be
um viable to do this but even when I
used to teach a large class uh made them
actually present make a presentation
although I was not there so that that
actually kind of break that a little bit
but how having the students think about
how to present stuff during class uh
even in the recorded sessions I think
there's a lot of value there um because
then they're really really thinking
about stuff that you're asking them
instead of using uh tools out
there um and there's this uh there's a
lot of research about now instead of
actually asking the students questions
we need to flip it around and tell the
students to ask good questions um so
making I mean this probably ties back to
what I was saying earlier where if you
make the questions more broad then the
students can actually think about going
in there thinking about you know what
variables are important here that I need
to visualize uh how will I visualize
them what kind of graphs will make the
uh the visualization compellent at least
in what I was doing uh in that class and
how do you communicate uh this result I
think communicating which is basically
given the Ora exam uh is so important um
but teaching them how to ask the
questions and I think that also goes
into making sure that they can actually
uh do research on their own I think uh
all of us can benefit from Tech
techniques to ask good questions and so
teaching our students early on to be
critical and to be able to come up with
very good questions uh will be the way
that for me at least uh where I'll be uh
giving exams in my my
courses so I think we are up on uh about
uh 50 1250 right now is in time so I'm
going to end here I had originally I had
a lot of material but I cut them short
because of time so uh I mean this is all
new to most of us and so if you have any
questions um uh you can put them in the
chat and Jack can read them out if you
have any thoughts uh we can also open
this for discussion too um but uh it's
all new so uh anyways um I'll I'll
arrest my kids here Prince thank you so
very much uh that was fun uh to to watch
you do that that was great you know one
of pardon me one of the things which is
interesting I mean you mentioned kind of
relevance and uh I I as I get older I
worry about this all the time and uh I'm
just thinking about you know we we've
talked a little bit about the use of AI
in biomedical research in particular as
being sort of like a as being a tool and
being something which is almost like a a
digital colleague and I'm curious about
maybe you could say something about chat
gbt is being sort of like a a virtual
research uh a teaching assistant if you
will um a co-teacher and it sounds like
some of the things that you're pitching
are uh and arguing about are are in
favor of that idea and I wanted to kind
of ask you if that is an accurate
statement yes I I totally agree with
that I think that and I think most of
the based on the result that I saw from
that uh little most of them most of us
are positive here I think that we should
it's an opportunity actually um even
those of us if all you do is teach them
CH GPT can actually help you or AI tools
can actually help you prepare for your
courses um um you can actually I think
what's going to happen is we we bur
models to do like Auto automated grading
for us so so that will probably take
away the job from the grader um but uh
automated grad and uh we'll be able to
also be able in research we could do
most of the stuff that we used to do
with a lot of time intensive stuff uh we
can just simplify that which really
really helps here um and um even just
going beyond that thinking about uh um
AI tools basically when I when I put a
prompt in whatever Char GPT or in the AI
to give me it's just a draft and they
come up with very very good draft um in
administration if you're sending a very
long email and you don't know where to
start you can get a draft first I mean
and you can develop it to make it to
personalize it to to your own style in
terms of students they have access to 24
hours uh Fant Service uh for free and I
think that is the opportunity that we
all need to uh wrap our hand around and
uh I think uh you're absolutely right uh
that it will help simplify most stuff
for us even as researchers as teachers
whatever uh and in the biomedical field
for sure yeah I think some of the things
that you know people and you sort of
expressed this people are a little bit
concerned about um the use of chat GPT
as effectively an easy way to plagiarize
right so they would use chat GP to
generate content and then turn it in uh
I'm curious if you have had any
experience and what your recommendations
would be for tools that exist that
detect the use of generative AI as the
source like for example if you someone
sends you a a a report and you run it
through a tool if it can tell you with
some degree of confidence whether or not
it was generated by a an AI do you have
any recommendations for that yeah that's
a very good point so um in terms of a of
a given exams in the classroom if the if
it's a coding course and they need their
computers and they need need um access
to the internet there are some um
software or there are some technology
out there that you can lock the student
screen so they are restricted to what
they just see um that sometimes avoid
that but in most most of the cases uh
you ask a report from students and you
know um they write like they are
Shakespeare you know they they write
like they have a absolute command of the
of of of the language and then when you
try to talk to them you're like did you
write this are you sure what you wrote
this and I think there's a lot of that
uh right now out there and so um and
it's also very hard uh if you're for
example if I tell my class not to use
chat GPT and they ended up use chat GPT
and I see that they actually you know
they plagiarize uh whatever their
thoughts
are um then for me to be able to say
take that leap and say that hey this is
coming from chat GPT that's a bigger
burden for me to be able to prove cuz I
wasn't there I don't know what they're
doing maybe they are maybe they can
write like sheshere but I can't really
um I can't really tell that maybe if I
was there and I see exactly what their
screens are maybe I could I could tell
um but otherwise we can't take that leap
and I think if you're going to uh uh
take students on for honor code
violations there's a bigger burden of us
as instructors to be able to prove that
um and so that's why thinking about more
open-ended cases and allowing them to
use it uh and let them critically think
about what they're doing for me is more
important and and I realize that that's
totally different from discipline to
discipline uh and the humanities uh
where they have to write a lot of papers
um yeah that is a big that's a big thing
uh I don't know how to avoid that maybe
you lock you lock the screen for them so
they cannot access any other thing on
their computers um but um in in data
science and biomedical science um I
could you could probably leave the
questions more open-ended so you can
actually really really get um you know
test the really critical understanding
of the material um but yeah it's it's uh
something that's plaguing higher
education big time um there's no it's
it's still ongoing and I think um we are
you know that's why I'm adopting as a
teacher uh in the classroom uh but
there's a lot of things that um we need
to do to be able to make sure that
what whatever we get from students are
authentic and is from them and stuff
like that we've put a focus on chat GPT
but um certainly uh generative AI is
used to create images and videos and
auditory um you know basically audio um
I was just hearing on NPR this morning
um NPR uh was kind of focused on this
issue a little bit especially in the
oncoming you know politic
season that we're entering here the use
of generative AI to create fictitious
content uh and deep fake material um you
having political candidates say stuff
they never said or rather show them
doing things they never did and I'm
curious if there are some things we need
to think about there as Educators it's
not just generating textual content but
for example you know if you could use
generative AI to include a figure from a
fictitious experiment um and pass it off
as it's real all of a sudden it's you
know like manufacturing data it's like
uh that would be a firable offense
certainly one that could get you
expelled but again we don't really have
a handle on that do you have any
thoughts about how we should handle
generative AI That's outside of just
text generation yeah so uh that's that's
what the the issue of a trustworthy AI
come in actually uh School data science
we're thinking about having a a course
that talks about that kind of concept
too I mean it's um it's unbelievable
like you said uh you can actually use it
to generate music uh you can use it to
make videos um yeah so and I think the
it's not just uh as Educators the burden
on us is actually to educate the
community and the country and you know
Global uh about you know understanding
of how CH GPT works and how it's using
um data from vast repository and
basically the span of the internet if
the data that is have access to is fake
then whatever the response is it's also
going to be fake um so it's uh it's in
incumbent upon us as Educators to be
able to help um educate the community
about AI um in general and I think uh I
want for one I want everybody that
graduated from in a university to know
that everything you get from chat GPT or
you know generated or generative AI in
general uh can be trusted um and so
that's why the critical thinking part
has to come in but yeah you're right um
there's a there's and a lot of people
don't know this uh if if a political
candidate tweak uh tweets or in this
case x uh put something on uh Twitter or
X um that is very negative and you know
Bas basically generated from AI
most people some people might believe it
um and so that's why we need some
critical thinkers to be able to go out
there and tell them hey you're this is
not true this is a fake news uh um so
it's a it's a thing that we are dealing
with as a society and I think uh people
need to be really really be educated uh
on that front for sure but yeah there's
not there's not a way there's not you
know a lot of ways to actually uh get
rid of that uh because that's all is
going to be some people who are going to
believe uh whatever they see out there
uh and uh I don't think I think in in
this age with everything being so easily
to to to make and to be able to generate
um we need to be very careful as a
people in general um so yeah it's a it's
a good point I don't have a very solid
answer for that either I think this
whole area is just fascinating and I
want to thank you Prince for sharing
some of your thoughts with this about
what we need to be thinking about in as
Educators and you know people who have
students who are very bright um and very
opportunistic to take advantage of these
things and so I want to thank you for
discussing with us some of the the
benefits of doing this but also some of
the the things we need to be aware of
and uh thank you so much and just to say
that Prince will be one of our mentors
at our uh biomedical data science
Innovation lab um in uh San Diego so
we're super excited to have him
interacting with our attendees um at our
uh event in June and so thank you Prince
and uh thank you everyone have a
wonderful Friday and a wonderful weekend
and uh take care we'll uh talk to you
next week bye now thank
you